let me go next to
um hold on a second here let's go to
kevin from new york
kevin from new york what's on your mind
today
holy crap i'm talking to david paxman
right now
you're on right now my friend i'm a big
fan
so basically a couple like two weeks ago
i was talking to my my friend talking
politics my friend
yeah and he opposes uh the res there was
the
because uh because
because they lose because of the whole
business and jobs
losing to businesses and jobs right and
where does your friend live
uh i i want to stay in anonymous
okay can you tell me what state your
friend lives in
uh i'm not sure he hasn't told me i just
want to stay anonymous
wait a second you have a friend and you
don't know what state they live in
that's very interesting friend he's a
discord friend
okay i'm not aware of any state that is
locked down right now so if your friend
lives in a different country then that
would be interesting to know
either i wasn't sure what he was talking
about either yeah but
hopefully he so basically i i i said
that we should give money to the
businesses
for we should give money to businesses
so they can pay their employees but he's
like
and due to unemployment but he's like no
because i'll start the rock
because that's why people are riding
wait he says people are rioting
when businesses get money for employees
he opposes unemployment benefits because
of that
your friend doesn't strike me as that
bright that's what i'm go that's my only
thought
yeah yeah i'm so sorry i mean i'm kind
of nervous because i'm speaking to you
you're doing great oh okay yeah
all right very good yeah i don't know
that i would argue with that friend i
would spend my time doing something more
productive this this friend doesn't
sound like they're making any sense
yeah yeah but what do you think i should
say
i would say listen i don't even know you
or know what state you live in
so it's i i i don't even know what
you're talking about and you know i'm
gonna go talk to somebody else on
discord that's my genuine advice
oh man okay thank you no problem
all right thank you very much if you
love feeding
your intellectual curiosity but you're
always struggling to find the time
check out one of my all-time favorite
apps
called blinkist blinkist lets you
consume an entire book
on your way home from work they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one into text or audio
that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks a month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video